one day more another day another fiery  its never-ending road to fire me this  matter pays me for my time I surely can  my ass for this crime Recordings you had  to be let go how could I not fire your  sorry gay ass one day tomorrow you'll  [ __ ] up again and yet you'll ask me for  a bonus one more chance enough to better  oh you do is cruel things are one more  chance to prove I'm able do you take me  for a fool still have your credit card  give it back or face my bruise is this  because you think I'm gay  yes you're mine I'd like some peanut  butter and I'd really like some cheese  then I'd like to have some ice cream and  to top it with sardines  send him up alone never know how much  Annie me till I'm gone here the little  sign will choose a side in this fight  based on who gives me ice cream since  that matters no fire  sure  I'm not gay  coming